[Music]
Beyonce bossy is one of Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Edition rookie and
the 32 year old beauty is sharing behind
the scenes swimsuit issues secrets only
with et so you wake up to their ears
like what time like I don't know because
you have to catch the lights or the
light in the morning and then you just
put on bathing suits and go around and
take pictures you know how many pictures
does it take to get one or two perfect
shots well it depends I feel like the
less clothes you have on yeah the less
time it takes because you don't really
need to make the outfit look good
how many days are you shooting for this
is it all in one day is it a week it was
one afternoon and then you know the
night before we are the fitting and it
took like I don't know maybe that's an
hour and I was just drawing bathing
suits after bathing suit on me how much
control do you have over your poses do
they ever ask you to do anything that
maybe you're not comfortable with or can
you make suggestions yes it happened
actually on this shoot - but you just
say like I don't feel and you know
there's so nice and they they were like
oh yeah don't worry you know but usually
I'm up for the challenge like you know
there really is this picture where I
have my like leg up here which is so
current and so painful - and in that
position I kept on getting cramps with
pointing the food it's just funny you
know because he looks so flawlessly but
really like it's uncle really you gotta
keep all the swimsuits or just select
ones yes well let's go back to the fact
that you are 32 but you're a rookie what
do you have to say to people who say
that modeling has an age limit
well you know I just think like you keep
on dreaming big you know I never put a
living to your dreams and believe that
everything can come true it's amazing no
I am a diabetic - and I'm proud of being
22 you know because I'm still looking
hard and I have the family of my dreams
[Music]